hier in der schuhmacherei werden sie
bestimmt nicht geschrieben die modernen
lebensentwürfe zwischen kick off meeting
und breakout session doch sind sie
realität für hunderttausende in
großraumbüros von konzernen wo sie sich
dann die hacken ihrer schuhe ablaufen
wer es schafft schafft es bis ins
mittlere kader und sieht man meistens
fest mittelmäßig frustriert und
hochgradig ausgebrannt der deutsche
autor frank jacob sieger zählt mit
eigener erfahrung und viel freude am
ungeschönten blick urbane legenden aus
der welt des real existierenden
kapitalismus seit anbeginn der
menschheit gehört die arbeit zum
menschsein der mensch verhindert die
umwelt durch seine arbeit aber auch die
arbeit verändert den menschen arbeit
diffamiert und moderner desto hefte
selbst wenn die arbeit eigentlich fertig
ist täglich zu beobachten in unserer
heutigen arbeitswelt die mit der
freizeit verschwinden in der nähe der
deutschen finanzmetropole frankfurt main
lebt der autor frank jacob sein buch mit
17 kurzen erzählung beschreibt die
arbeitswelt der it und beraterbranche
aus der innenperspektive geografischen
bezug dazu und es erschien mir dann als
ich in dem biografischen bezug sonst
jahre nicht mehr hatte sinnvoll diesen
bereich auch aus zu sehen weil da so
viele leute arbeiten und weil es sehr
moderne die in der realität so kopiert
auch in jacobs erzählungen immer mehr
die arbeitswelt das privat eine ständige
geistige rufbereitschaft ist
selbstverständlich im mittleren
management die helden seiner erzählung
nehmen es als auszeichnung viel zu
arbeiten mehr als ihre vorfahren
aber stimmt das überhaupt deren leben
nicht von wesentlich härterer arbeit
geprägt die die rasch altern und früh
sterben gibt es ist nicht mehr die
physisch hatte aber er ist psychisch
druck der die heutige arbeitswelt zu
halten
[Musik]
was uns so nach zugehörigkeit streben
lässt ist vermutlich die uralte angst
von der horde alleingelassen zu werden
und dann sterben zu müssen und das ist
eine sehr starke triebkraft offenbar
auch im modernen menschen die es wird
offenbar nicht reflektiert in der regel
und die solle auch gesellschaftlich
nicht reflektiert werden weil sich damit
so furchtbar viel gutes anfangen lässt
wie zum beispiel profitmaximierung seine
helden allesamt kleine chef der
mittleren ebene
sie wollen dazu gehören zur weltweit
agierenden firma ich selbst als global
player fühlen
dazu gehören zu denen die tolle
smartphones brauchen weil sie überall
erreichbar sein müssen
in einer erzählung für hat ein manager
später am abend in seine wieder farbenen
cabriolet nachreichen gedanken schnitzen
und seine arbeitswelt kann sie mit dem
kopf und verbinden sich auf der
schnellen autofahrt mit der fantasie
niemals anzukommen
die autofahrt nicht zu überlegen in
dieser erzählung das widerfahren
cabriolet ging es mir darum zu zeigen
dass jemand in so einer großen
drucksituationen vollständig produzieren
muss und gar nicht weiß was er
eigentlich produziert mit sicherheit in
seiner fantasie den tod attraktiver
findet und finden muss als dieses leben
und damit schafft er sich wieder den
ausgleich und dann ruhig bin ganz sicher
dass diese figur am nächsten tag wieder
pünktlich zur arbeit geht zurück ins
laufrad also so wie alle helden aus den
anderen erzählungen von jakob geht
einfach weiter funktionieren
eine scharfsinnige analyse unserer
arbeitswelt aber große literatur ist das
nicht
denn jakubczyk personal bleibt da nur
allesamt klar im recht blass und
austauschbaren sicher der dresscode
macht die branche uniform doch hinter
dem outfit spürt der leser keine mensch
er den verächtlichen blick des autors
auf die arbeitswelt ohne empathie
präsentierte seine figuren wie ein
wissenschaftler das versucht ihr zu dumm
für einen ausweg den kranken oder autor
die lösung im gesellschaftlichen sinne
ist ganz klar eine tragische bücher
lesen sich mit literatur befassen sich
von mir aus auch mit kunst befassen oder
musik dingen die einfach nur sie selbst
sind wie dieser vogel wir da oben
quatscht die keinen sinn haben keine
funktionen keinen nutzen
der lockruf von games und bedeutung hält
die meisten fest zum ihre arbeit zwingen
nur wenige steigen aus noch seltener
schreibt jemand ein buch darüber
einer von ihnen ist frank jacob schick